who can you tell us the camera that you
purchased what was it again I was a red
scarlet okay and what were the major
factors in you purchasing that camera
and why didn't you rent it versus just
outright buying it mm-hmm um I think
it's a really tough question for people
to I think you and when you make those
decisions you don't necessarily know at
the time whether it's the right or the
wrong decision you just sort of have to
go off of a sense and in a projection of
what you're going to be working on the
reason that I liked the red was I felt
it did a lot of things in the camera
that other cameras needed you needed to
attach a lot of doodads to you know
whether if you wanted to get 4k on
another camera you have to attach an
external recorder normally if you want
to record to compress raw that's not
even an option for most of these other
cameras even though red has been doing
it now for five years so I felt like it
was something that once they were
getting supported by editing systems so
you can just drag in our 3d files to the
timeline and cut natively it was
something that gave you a lot of
flexibility for high-end projects
something that you could go shoot a
feature on but also something that you
could use you know as a compact package
to go film an interview you know so the
versatility of the tool is what made me
think I'm comfortable investing in this
because it goes in different directions
whereas I think some of the other
cameras are more specialized in their
limitations hold you back from certain
productions but you know the camera
market is changing I don't know that
I'll be shooting on a red forever you
don't know what's coming out around the
corner you know but thankfully most of
these professional tools holder value
decently so when you're selling or you
know red has an upgrade program so just
just the idea that it's going to last
you for a number of years is the the
calculation for me is thinking about how
much use can I get out of this and for
how long and was that also what factored
into you purchasing it rather than
renting it's kind of like leasing a car
versus buying it did you know that there
will be additional things I want to
shoot with it this is not the last time
I'm going to
this or I think as indie filmmakers we
have this romantic idea that if you own
the equipment you're not going to be
held back from having an idea and going
and shooting something for no money with
your friends and getting it in the can
because you already spent the money on
the camera so it's not costing you
anything to go make this movie right and
there's nothing wrong with that idea and
I certainly share that myself and you
know i think that's that's kind of like
the the calculation behind buying
something because typically if you're
only going to rent you know for me I'm
not doing freelance work I'm working on
my own projects and so it takes me a lot
of time to write and go through
pre-production and do that I'm not going
to be using the camera that many days
out of the year but I do like the idea
that oh I we can go make this thing with
with the equipment we have as opposed to
like setting up a budget and getting
production insurance and getting rentals
and having to build that whole thing
every time you go shoot something
you